reject so the mic is working right okay
um now the slides are
missing but anyways first of all thank
you all for showing up at this amazing
conference and also a special thanks for
the organizers of this uh conference not
only because they are letting me speak
today but because it's hard and
important work to organize open
community events and I would like you
all to give them a round of applause
now so hi um Ola already did the
introduction thank you for that um
you can find me anywhere on the web as
bamman and yes that's for ends
um stop scratching your own
itch um this talk is not technical there
is not a single line of code and also
there's no life coding obviously there's
a plus uh that's a plus for me
and what I want to talk about today is
um experiences and observations I made
in our industry in the tech industry in
the past years and what my personal
consequences are and maybe what you can
get out of
it
so who of you knows the book rework by
37 signals or now base camp okay that's
quite a
lot um I'll explain it anyways it's it's
a business book it has many short
chapters with um yeah some some um tips
on how to to run your business and one
of the one of the chapters that sticked
most with me was scratch your own itch
and was it uh what it says basically is
the easiest way to create a great
product is to make something you want to
use what it means is if you are your own
customer you don't need user studies you
don't need Market studies because you
know when it's right because you want to
use it and you need your own problem to
to be
solved what this says is it's the
easiest way to create a product but it
does not contain any statement about the
value you are
creating it's it's a valid Mantra and it
works in fact but it's easy to
interpret let us watch a short film now
I'm hungry I'm hungry famished I am
famished order a pizza yeah order pizza
Pizza I can go for a pizza I want pizza
but I don't want to order a pizza I wish
there was like a button you know and all
you have to do was push that button and
then Pizza comes wait say that again
yeah I wish I had a button I could push
for pizza a button you could push for
pizza yeah yeah like like an app and
it's just got one button on it and that
one button pizza pizza so like an iPhone
app and and we'll uh make it so you only
put your information in once and you'll
never have to do it again never again
just one button and you push it push it
for pizza push for pizza
we have to make it we have to yeah we'll
make one of those videos where where I I
turn to the camera and I'm like uh are
you tired of ordering uh Pizza by
pressing buttons or you want pizza yes
do you want pizza and do you want it now
I want to wear a suit if you want pizza
and don't want to spend a lot of time
finding a place put your credit cards
and say it's like uber for pizza
that's kind of stupid we can't say Uber
two choices for now to keep it simple
plain and pepperoni just pick your
preference then then push the button
push the button push for
pizza yippee the push for Pizza app
sends out your request along with your
payment info and pizza preference and
hot pizza shows up at your door all paid
up even the tip push for
pizza so um can you giz uh guess which
site posted it like the onion or college
humor or is it in dependent YouTube
channel anyone knows
maybe okay so let's just watch the end
of the
film yeah it's real download for free on
the App
Store this is a real
product
um there's an app in the app store I
read blog post it works um Pizza shows
up at your
door and they've got quite some press
coverage as well
so these guys really scratch their own
agge
um I want to emphasize the scratch part
here because um imagine you have a
mosquito bite and it itches
terribly and what's the one thing every
every person says to you it's don't
scratch and why is that because even
though it's super pleasing to scratch
your own itch
it makes it worse so um you might hurt
your skin I I know what I'm talking
about I have some scars on my arms
because I keep scratching and we are
actually making things worse by
scratching so they are having this this
urgent feeling for um for pizza and so
they give in they're seized by the
desire and then they build an app it's
called push for pizza but um soon sooner
or later this app will harm them
physically because they're losing um
taste they're losing the relationship to
food and also they have to come up with
an fitness app real
soon this is
hellofresh they deliver delicious Reyes
and the matching ingredients to your
door every
week and I haven't tried to service and
it it it's not even about the service
it's more about
the their approach of of solving
problems rather than
scratching because they're they're
solving the the same problem really
because um if you have the right
ingredients if you have a resy at home
they are actually preventing this urge
for food to happen in the first place
but in a in a much more
um yeah um maintainable way for for the
humans and they are not scratching they
are
solving here's the next service and I'm
really sorry that these are all Food
Services because I'm between uh you and
your lunch but
um let's go through it
um this is reservation hop what they do
is they call um restaurants under fake
names and Reserve seeds and then they
can sell these reservations to people
who are willing and able to pay for
them scratch your own
itch science says that an itch is uh is
something that happens in your brain and
only there so um you probably know that
um that your arm is itching and then or
your head is is itching and you have to
scratch it somehow and then there's
nothing there's really nothing so it's
like I just made it up for you sincerely
your brain it's nothing and what
reservation Hub does is they they don't
they don't have problems left so they
invent invent something by making
reservations at restaurant scars in the
first place by faking the reservations
and then they are selling them so
they're really um solving the problem
that they created in the first
place
there's the Detroit Water Project and
they connect donors with people in need
in the Detroit area where the economy is
really bad and so like 300,000 people
are um threatened of their their water
being cut off because they can't um pay
the bills anymore and they um have a
process that matches the donors with the
people in need without much bureaucracy
or or anything that that hinders them to
to pay their bills and and now this
solves a real problem um they probably
cannot solve the econom uh the economy
economic crisis there but they're at
least having a real impact on on some
people's lives it's a real
problem and then there's you probably
all um heard it or read about it the
standard markdown or no uh or now common
Mark
disaster where um some guys I guess guys
exclusively um said they want to have a
standard for markdown and then they came
up with uh something and the person who
originally invented um markdown uh
grber um he he he didn't want it to
happen he didn't want um to use the the
markdown name and um especially not
standard markdown and he also said
markdown is uh got so successful because
there is no real spec and all that kind
of stuff
and I don't want to say that anyone of
them is right it's the scratch your own
agge part um everyone in this um debate
is basically solving their own problem
and only their own so um of course sites
like stack exchange or GitHub uh have a
real interest that markdown is somehow
standardized as their whole service um
relies on on that for the system and
markdown um paring and rendering in
general but it's just it's just about
their own perspective and also grba it's
how about his personal feelings or his
trademark or whatever but there's no
real problem and um it's it's just like
it it feels like we ran out of real
problem problems to
solve um that's not the case obviously
but it seems like if you only can can
can solve your own problem and if we if
you look at the demographics of of the
people who are able to solve problems we
see that it's a very um homogeneous
group of um mostly white male people and
they sove their own problems and then
people who have real problems they can't
solve it so there there are some steps
to fix it the first one is to enable
more people to be able to fix their own
problems so we don't have to invent
problems or scratch problems any longer
we can just enable other people to solve
problems and um that means we can
organize or attend meetups we can
organize conferences we can care
especially about I uh a diverse lineup
of speakers and also attendees um we can
we can of course also only attend it but
we can focus on the communication we can
explicitly try to talk to people that
are different than
ourselves and to if we somehow notice
someone is isn't feeling comfortable or
something we can we can address them and
and help them to to to not quit um
technology and to keep going so they can
solve their own problems and the second
part is
that if you want to solve like really
big problems with of
impact um it won't work if if um only
small group works on their own problem
but we need diverse teams to to do that
and you might not always be in in charge
of of of hiring decisions but for me
it's like um I demand um I a diverse
teams I speak up for it and I don't want
to work in um non- diverse teams any
longer
so as Ola already told um I did an
internship at hoodie for the last two
month and um it's ending on Monday sadly
but now it can be told um but it's it's
actually about my experience there and
what I what I um what I saw is first I
have to explain what hoodie really is
it's a web application framework that
kind of abstracts backend tasks and
gives you generic backend so you can um
build your own um serious applications
that have users and data and sync and
email and all that kind of stuff without
being a backend um developer
professional or whatever you can just
build serious applications with just
front-end knowledge and for one I really
like that because that enables more
people to realize their their own ideas
and to fix their own
problems and on the other hand such a
problem cannot be solved by just the
experts who are building the application
now um the the actual hoodie framework
came out of an application that one of
the founders built for themselves but um
from that point on it would probably not
have been his own problem any longer
because he fixed it and now he could
have spent his time on building some
awesome plugins for whatever he could
use but they're trying to fix problems
for for other people and also um to make
it really easy for them but if only
these experts are trying to to build
that solution it won't it won't work can
can't be a a top down solution but also
there there needs to be a diverse team
to um work on something like hoodie
there need to be more people than just
developers they need to be
Communications act uh communication
experts there need to be people who
write documentation who have a different
angle on things because you know if
you're working on the same thing all the
time you have different angle you don't
even know how it feels to get to it when
when you're new so you need input from
other people
and that's that's what I learned there
basically that it's it's a joy to work
of course but it's also the the only
maintainable way to fix real problems
that have an
impact so now for something different um
Toyota developed cars using the lean
manufacturing
philosophy and one central part of this
is the endon
cord what it does
is there is basically cord at every
workstation in the Factory and if
someone pulls the court the entire
production Hall stops and production is
um broken down entirely until this one
problem is solved and basically every
person in the room or in the factory can
have 100% of the attention at any time
then they fix the the issue and then
they go on and what do you think how
often is this court pulled in one day at
at a Factory like is it one day is it
one once per day hands up is it 10 times
per
day 50
100,000 not so sure but my first thought
is
that this is something to to put force
on on the workers so they know if
something goes wrong the entire
production is is stopped but in fact the
court is pulled about 5 thousand times a
day and they're since they since they're
doing this this is the the most
productive um they had the most
productive runs ever so they're doing um
2,000 cars a day and that is because
everyone is aware of other people other
um other problems and if you have an
scratch your own AG um mindset
you probably think why should I stop my
work or my production line if someone
over there has a problem you know we can
just continue and then it's somehow
fixed and then we continue and it's all
fine but the problem uh but but the
reality is that that that doesn't work
we can't leave people
behind and I tried to talk about my own
experiences in this talk but I also um
want to try to pull the end in cord on
us all um I want you
to um pay attention to to other
workstations to other people to talk to
them to not leave them behind to
um fix their
problems before you go on with your own
work and I can tell tell you um what
what you should create or um how you
should do it but um as I said we can we
can solve serious problems um if we if
we don't think about this if we don't
think about having diverse um teams and
having um a focus on real problems
rather than just privileged itches we
are trying to fix with an nap because
it's cool or something we have to to
look Beyond and um what it means is we
should not scratch our own itch but
solve real problems
together thank
you
reject